uh there's a guy named Max tagmark at
MIT who really worries about nuclear war
and he was part of uh constructing a
simulation of what happens when a
nuclear war happens it's interesting to
see that uh you know some very large
percentage of humans on Earth uh starve
to death
because they don't die first from the
explosion they die from starvation
because uh basically uh dust covers the
entire North America and entirety of
Europe
and so the cops all die all the food
sources all die and people suffocate and
starve to death
but you know the lesson you'll learn
from that over a period of a few months
even though most of the human population
of Earth dies
Earth
finds a way life finds a way to do that
yeah to adapt and it's gonna be just
fine yeah in terms of the big uh living
ecosystem that is life on Earth
and yeah it's humbling to think about
well maybe we're just the stepping stone
same thing with we've talked offline
about artificial intelligence maybe
humans are just a stepping stone to the
development of these other
super intelligent entities yeah
yeah
and is it
unconsciously in our nature that that's
just part of the evolution and
adaptation
of our species and we'll because we're
gonna
we were talking about earlier what AI
becomes
this completely 100 based on Who We Are
and we get to see it for some time a
mirror to ourselves okay this is what
human civilization is like these uh
AI systems large language models are
trained on human communication and you
get to ask it questions you get to have
conversations with it you get to realize
wow this is what
the uh the collective intelligence of
the human species are collective wisdom
and knowledge is what it looks like
all the bias the hate
um
the paradoxes all that is in there yeah
uh
the contradictions
you can even convince those models you
can you can tell them they're lying and
they're going to start changing their
mind it's interesting to play with them
it's also interesting to consider that
maybe they uh
they become smarter than us and
uh become almost life forms that live
among us and maybe one day
kind of we merge with them there's all
kinds of possible
trajectories that we take here how much
did that excite you how much of it
scares you
is it possible to exist in a place where
it is both exciting and scary but to
exist in that dance
mostly I'm really excited
because
I see human beings as deeply lonely like
there's a deep loneliness at all this is
how we seek connection
that's why we see connection others
that's why love is so beautiful when we
find other people we're connected with
and I just think AI can add to that you
can add
friends that you can have
great conversations with
and there's some of those friends would
be AI systems
they'll call you out and you're
in the most fascinating and interesting
of ways
and challenge you and help you uh
explore ideas together so I'm excited by
that
is that different and if so how from
the internet and Facebooks and these
groups and communities that
were I think it's fair to say set out to
say this all access of information and
people will help us find more common
denominators then
divisive ones
um is is it you see it similar yeah it's
similar but further into that direction
I think the internet has done an amazing
thing in connecting us and expanding our
minds and helping us find community
that feels like our community and then
the communities that are totally
different you learn from them I mean
Wikipedia alone one of my favorite
websites
just opens your mind to all kinds of
cool stuff yeah it does
and so uh I think AI just open makes
that even easier because Wikipedia you
have to like read and have to do a lot
of work
uh with an AI system like a larger
language model you can just shoot the
it's more like drinking a beer
versus like uh doing homework yeah yeah
yeah yeah
it's already happening what do you think
about that becoming the new family to
where
you know you said you know marriage you
don't have kids could you see a future
for yourself whether you have a
relationship with AI and that is your
family and that's the main that's the
primary like even a romantic
relationship yeah
I can see it that one worries me
I like to keep it at friends right
I think I'm not ready to commit to the
romance
um it's I wonder how much that now that
takes us back to the Amazon in nature
how much we still need the human touch
yeah and whatever magic there is between
two humans which takes the leap into the
romantic
versus just the intimacy of a good
friendship I don't know
so
correct if I'm wrong you you see AI is
having a deep and meaningful friendship
yes
and hopefully it will be a friend that
will help you evolve and be able to love
even more and be loved and you can take
that into humanity and find another Homo
Sapien yes to go
yes
and thank you AI my great friend for
opening me up to this beauty that I have
myself I can see in you
my fellow
human and let's come together and
biologically create family if we want to
and let's all remain friends with my
friend and make your own friends with my
friends friends on AI and let's have
these great
neighbor it's a good friend that great
friend that's a neighbor okay mentor and
friend just like uh now there's AI
systems that play chess far far far
better than humans and we humans still
play chess with each other
or the chess is still a game that's fun
for us humans right and then we use AI
systems to get better just to learn to
train to discover new ideas but
ultimately return to the chess board
between two humans
uh but of course this world is full of
dangerous people and so those same AI
systems can be used to um
to harm to create false narratives to uh
do social engineering and manipulate the
masses
in terms of what they believe and all
that kind of stuff that's scary yeah
well and I I get it when we and I have
my own fear and distrust is
of AI is based on my own fear and
distrust of myself and others
there's something it's very simple but I
think it's it's a really fun
sort of
way to just set up this reality and
everyone it's kind of a duh but it still
needs to be said that
AI is a prompt is there it doesn't do
anything unless we ask it
[Music]
so
what questions
yeah are we gonna ask is a question is
what we need to ask ourselves because
we're going to be looking in the mirror
at our digital God that we create
from ourselves and just to know that
that's that place where it's awesome and
scary exciting against care we go oh
it's it's our creation
which is awesome
at the same time oh
but it's it's prompted by our questions
and gives us patterns
from when that which we give it
but that prompting
that's uh that's the art of life like we
prompt each other in conversation our
loved ones when you when you
when you go about your day-to-day the
next words you say the next word you say
to me the question I ask
of you that's prompting yeah and it
could change everything I could say so
many things right now that will
completely just the the the the the the
set of possibilities
where both of our Lives can take given
on the selection of words I use and you
use
it is crazy so it makes conversation fun
yay and then same thing with AI
except the nice thing about AI is it's
tireless
tireless right let me ask you this if
you can falsely condemn me right now and
I prove you falsely condemn me
I can forgive you
and we can March forward stronger than
before yes
in ai's tirelessness
and retention
can forgive
I mean Can Can it can it go oh oh okay
yep sorry about that one I was wrong can
it amend yes
yeah you could prompt it to ask for
forgiveness it'll forgive you like when
I talk it around with it
and you ask what should I be afraid of
here or is there it's the Dooms toward
the
it's answer was always well it's up to
you
because she was awesome right yeah there
you go again it's up to us and it
brought up
you know make me synonymous with your
human values and ethics and
responsibilities but it doesn't deal
that I didn't find anyway deal with
defining or making choices on its own of
what those are
yeah I think uh some of that is manually
uh those are constraints put on by it by
the creators of those large language
models
basically
not letting the systems have an identity
of Their Own
and some of it is just not engineered in
yet but I believe that we'll have
uh systems that have an identity have a
belief have a set of opinions like that
carry through time
and will we go to them like certain
states where we you agree with the law
and disagree with the law or nations and
I'm a member
of this AI oh well you're from this AI
tribe you all believe this
yeah there will be an anarchist set of
AIS they'll be the Communists there will
be the uh the Nazis there will be the
Democrats and the Republicans there will
be the people who are on the keto diet
and the people that are on this other
kind of diet this other kind of
lifestyle that just like we have now
there's little groups and there'll be AI
systems they're going to be supercharged
yeah
they'll they'll be either the leaders or
the foundation on which we build those
groups and it'll be it'll be
uh the possibility of all the fun we can
have
is endless of course the danger is
always rise up there because I mentioned
the Nazis I mentioned that all the
dangerous ideas this is the the set of
ideas that humans have come up with a
lot of them are awesome most of them are
awesome I would say but some of them are
dangerous
the reason they're dangerous is because
they become viral there's something
exciting in us about those ideas but
they also harm others a lot
because that's who we are as humans
we're uh we're capable of envy and all
the dark stuff of hate and all this
capable yes
we also
choose it
do you think most people are good
yes
but I also
believe we've got we got the good and
evil in all of us and it's which one
which which wolf we've eaten